[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: To get
started with Pub/Sub,
first make sure the Pub/Sub API
is enabled for your project.
Then go to the Pub/Sub page
in the Google Cloud Platform
console.
Click Create a Topic.
Enter a unique name
for your topic--
for example, My Topic.
That's it.
You've just created a
Cloud Pub/Sub topic.
To add a subscription
to the topic
you've just created,
use the Display
menu for the topic
you've just created
and click New Subscription.
Type a name for the
subscription, MySub.
This is case-sensitive,
so do make sure
you capitalize the M and the S.
Leave the delivery type
as Pull, and click Create.
To publish a message
to the topic,
in the Overflow menu for the
topic you've just created,
click Publish Message.
Enter Hello World in
the message field.
Click Publish.
To receive the message
you just published,
your subscription needs to
perform a pull operation.
One way to do this is through
the G Cloud command line tool.
You can use the Google
Cloud SDK locally.
But here, we'll use the
in-console cloud shell
to run the following G Cloud
command from the guide.
The message you sent
appears in the data field
of the command output.
Congratulations.
You've just created a Cloud
Pub/Sub topic, subscription,
and pull request to
that subscription.
[MUSIC PLAYING]